[Music]
as an offensive lineman you're always
working behind the scenes you know how
to you know handle success
humbly
because when you have that success your
your name's not going to be printed in a
newspaper article maybe you know you get
a shout out you know the o-line as a
unit would get a shout out from the
running backs quarterbacks coaches
whatever but we knew to never get too
high after success never get too low you
know if there's any kind of failure that
it just really took you know five guys
to you know grind day in and day out and
look to keep getting better and build as
a unit
my name is jared veldir i grew up in
grand rapids michigan uh born and raised
football even professional football you
know i didn't really see that in my
future much like maybe college football
but i like basketball a lot more coach
otterbein came and watched one of my
basketball games
and then offered me a scholarship to
play football after and
uh i accepted pretty quick because i was
already familiar with the school my
brother went there played basketball
there i i could see uh you know the
value in being at an institution like
that for four plus years
the nfl thought first popped in my head
after my
freshman year i was able to put on some
good size strength and speed and a
couple guys just started joking about it
like hey you're just as big as these
guys that are you know getting drafted
or you know in the combine and that are
playing in the nfl and it never seemed
too stressful and it just seemed kind of
you know a lighthearted fun goal to go
about you we finished our our football
season in november and then immediately
i signed with an agent and that whole
process started to go um you know heard
my name called with the 69th pick in the
in the in the draft
which was the third round
just uh kind of a whirlwind you know
just instant like elation and then just
craziness
looking back at the transition between
division two and the nfl getting moved
from left tackle the right tackle
probably sticks out is the biggest
challenge
because i played left tackle my whole
time at hillsdale and played left tackle
for the first seven years of the nfl
career and when i took those initial
right tackle sets and it just felt so
awkward you know my body was just so
programmed to move from from a
left-handed stance i mean i
wanted to
[Music]
basically quit in training camp because
i felt like i was just so worthless and
that i was you know no longer that one
of those five guys that was accountable
to one another and that i couldn't do my
job and i didn't want to do that to the
group and the team and it's never fun
when you have to learn through playing
in front of you know 60 000 plus people
but uh
again just kind of keep your head down
and try to get better and correct things
and fix it as you go and that's what i
did and figured it out and so it's nice
being able to
take some of those lessons and now uh
you know try to apply them outside of
football you know trying to to raise a
young family and you know now being back
in west michigan and you know just
life-changing sometimes you feel like
you can maybe lose your footing but with
what i've you know learned i'm able to
kind of stay grounded if that makes
sense
you know something that everyone who's
gone to hillsdale's heard you know a
million times it's the people
and i think it really applies because uh
you know without that great group of
people there i don't know how many
people would stick around and survive
and thrive and have a really you know
good academic career athletic career
whatever it is there it's a it's a tough
place so it was a losing record my
freshman year and then uh it seemed like
each year i think it was each year we we
had gotten better improved uh and then
my senior year we had made it to the
division two playoffs for the first time
in school history and coach otterbein
was a great coach
you know i
really you know tipped my hat to him
being able to work with
18 to you know 22 year old
kids and turn him into men and i think
that was
always his number one goal and you when
you're going through you know the same
kind of challenges the same difficulties
the same you know stages of life and uh
you know you're doing it together you
know non-stop uh you need to forge some
really special relationships and was
definitely able to do that at hillsdale
not trying to put words in your mouth
coach otter but
you know if you can mold those those
good men those good human beings that
the winds would follow that because that
was the most important piece without
that then the winds wouldn't happen